on campaign check we're scrutinizing
claims made on the election trail today
it's the Green Party and their aim to
invest 1 trillion pounds over the next
10 years to make the UK carbon neutral
by 2030 that's 20 years earlier than the
current government target one key plank
a pledge to build 100,000 new
energy-efficient council homes and
retrofit energy and insulation upgrades
for a million more properties that's
going to cost ten point two billion
pounds for the new homes and twenty four
point six billion pounds a year for the
retrofitting of existing stock now this
matters because housing accounts for
about fourteen percent of all UK
greenhouse gas emissions so can this
manifesto be delivered it will require
an unprecedented increase in the pace of
council house building you can see from
this chart the number has been
decreasing since the mid 90s over there
nearly 60,000 a year it's down to fewer
than 7,000 homes built in England last
year and the Greens are promising to
build 100,000 a year for 10 years
upgrading existing housing to the
highest energy efficiency standards may
actually be an even bigger challenge
than that in England just 1% of homes
have the highest energy rating of a or B
and the Greens are proposing an even
higher standard known as a passive house
and there are just 1000 of those in the
UK transforming these numbers is a huge
challenge it would be unprecedented the
current government has committed to
upgrading 2.2 and a half million homes
for those who fuel poverty
juster energy rating C which isn't even
the highest rating and they're on
schedule to deliver that by 2091 rather
than 2030 so this is extremely
challenging it's very ambitious the
Greens have long warned of a climate
emergency in this election the political
Kent's consensus has finally caught up
with them but they're targets to become
carbon neutral by 2030 remain decades
ahead of the opposition and it appears
ability to achieve them meeting the
housing pledge depends on an
unprecedented increase in the capacity
and skills of the construction industry
which could take ten years to get up to
speed let alone start delivering